so i'm thrilled to be here and i'm
thrilled to be talking about joy
and even more i'm thrilled to be
collaborating with sam aaron who you'll
see and talk with shortly and meta x
and it should be a lot of fun so the way
this is going to work is i'm going to
talk for like a small amount of time
and then sam's going to come in and he's
going to talk for a small amount of time
and then
if everything's willing we're going to
have live-coded music and dancing robots
but
so much stuff could go wrong there's
like so many failure points
but it'll be fun we're all in this
together right
so um so let's get started
so when i meet someone new and uh they
ask me what i do
and i say i'm a software developer
and if they're not you know in our
community they kind of look at me and
the question comes their
tongues and they say do you like that
maybe followed by
isn't that boring
and i look them straight in the eyes and
i say i love it
which kind of confuses them a little bit
more and they usually follow up and say
like why
so i usually follow this up with a
question that i asked them
i asked them
have you ever had flying dreams you know
like when you're little and like you
float up in your dream and all of a
sudden you're like oh my gosh i'm flying
this is so freaking cool
well
that's how i feel like i'm when i'm in
the zone coding
and they'll still look a little bit
confused so i'll ask them another
question
have you ever had one of those dreams
where like you finally understand it all
right there is a handstand but have
these dreams
and then you forget it like right when
you wake up
has anybody ever like remembered it when
they woke up because that would be
really cool wow
excellent
excellent
nice
well that's how i feel when i finally
solve a programming problem it's awesome
and if they're still confused and
they're still listening to me and they
haven't run away
i tell them about when i was little and
like on a summer morning i was about
eight years old and i bicycled as fast
as i could to my favorite playground
because in this playground near it
there was this grove of trees that was
like magical to me it was it was just
like a magical place full of wonder
and at that moment i would look around
in the trees and i was utterly convinced
that any moment i would see a unicorn
and that's the same wonder and i feel
when i'm exploring a new technology
so all these things are why i love
programming so much
and together
they're sort of the personal joy of
programming
and uh
yeah i love it
but it's fragile
right you need to take care of it
because it can be diminished it can
you know seem like it might disappear
but luckily there's some
things that you can do they're common
sense that we all know but it's always
good to go over them again
to take care of your personal joy
so one of them of course is take care of
yourself get enough sleep i know
especially after this conference i want
to like stay up to two or three a.m and
you know look at all the interesting
papers and languages that have been
presented
but after a few days of that
the rest of my joy
gets pretty diminished
likewise you know take care of yourself
eat good
food exercise
and of course keep interested and keep
learning keep that flame alive and all
of you are certainly doing this by
attending this wonderful conference
for me my passion is closure i love
closure and i remember when i was first
playing with closure and also these
paired ar german quadcopters which are
fabulous
and i was late one night after the kids
were in bed and i had the closure rebel
open and i was trying to get the
quadcopter and send it the udp commands
to actually take off
and i had it right next to me and i
pushed the replica command and it took
off and i totally wasn't expecting it
and i screamed
i was like oh my gosh it worked
and at that moment i was flying with the
drone it was great
so we've talked about things that can
keep your joy strong that you have under
your control
but sometimes stuff happens that's
totally out of your control right
a life happens
sickness happens illness happens
loved ones pass away
and in fact i lost a dear friend and
colleague and mentor of mine this spring
and quite frankly
i was devastated
joy just totally left the world
it was great for me even the closure
code and the programming that i loved
just wasn't there
and
i knew that this was part of the normal
grieving process
but it was still really really hard
and i remember
one night i was sitting at the kitchen
table again trying to get interested in
something and i had the closure rebel
open
and i was trying out this
program called a library called overtone
which enables you to
make music with code
enclosure
and i don't know music at all i can't
read music i've never played an
instrument in my life
but somehow with code i was able to make
sounds
and even music
and that point
it was like a ray of light like the joy
had finally filtered back into my life
again and i thought this was
really
fitting because
it wasn't the joy my joy that reached me
it was a shared joy of the community
that came to me in that dark time
because um overtone is an open source
open source project created by jeff rose
and sam aaron and they took their joy
and they shared it with the community
which was then shared with me
and in fact the song that i finally
managed to play even though i have no
musical talent at all was a song from
daft punk
and that made me smile and cry but that
was okay
and it was good and
i thought it was fitting also that the
joy that i felt was from the community
because a person that i was grieving for
during that time was jim weirich
who passed away this spring
and uh a lot of you may have known him
he is creator rake he loved music he was
a wonderful speaker and teacher and he
spoke here at strange lib in 2012.
so we miss you jim
he
was always filled with joy
he was filled with personal joy
full of wonder and excitement for new
things whether it was y combinators or
robots
and he took this joy and he shared his
joy with the community
through open source through teaching
through speaking all over the world and
just inspiring other people
and he was a true caretaker of this
shared joy in our community
he always always treated others with
kindness and respect
there were no stupid questions with him
he enjoyed talking with beginners as
well as experts and it didn't even
matter to him if you were a programmer i
would remember our office i'd come back
from lunch and he was showing the
maintenance worker his drone that he was
working on and you know explaining the
whole library it just truly didn't
matter he was sharing his joy with
everyone
so our shared joy is so important not
only does it increase our personal joy
because sharing joy
increases it
but it also binds us together as a
community this is why we are all here
and it lifts us up in times where we
need help or we're you know just in a
dark place
but most importantly it makes us more
than ourselves
so i would like to say thank you
i'd like to say thank you for being part
of the community that i love so much
and i urge you all to keep it strong
with joy love respect and kindness
and of course music robots and unicorns
so i'm going to turn it over to sam now
and um i might be hooking up some robots
while he's talking
hello
hello
what a beautiful talk i don't know how
to move on from there i'm going to stand
over here maybe that's my makeup hello
hello i'm sam aaron here's my slides
where are we no it's not even
there we are okay i need to stay over
here the range is there so you might
know me as one of the guys who created
overtone um they don't hear used
overtone
that's amazing thank you very much thank
you
it's beautiful and when we talk about
sharing our joy of programming
a lot of my joyful programming comes
exactly from hearing people using my
software and it's a really beautiful
thing and it inspires me to carry on um
and one of the ways i'm trying to
encourage people to to use the kinds of
things i'm doing like
the the main joy for me is as promoting
and communicating the the creativity
that you can have when you can code the
new things that we can do not just
coding is for apps and websites which is
something we hear all the time and has
professionals that's probably where we
get most of our sort of employment from
but as we know
coding is so much more than apps and
websites right and so what could it be
it could be
a form of a new form of interacting with
music so this is me and jonathan we are
meta x we were performing here at
strange loop this is a photo of us
performing just a couple of nights ago
and you can see we've got the code
behind us projected
we've got these crazy devices which are
data structures with physical data
structures there are actually uh there's
persistent data structures backing there
every time you press a button creates a
new event that event receives an
immutable list of all the other button
presses you've had an entire session and
you can in the function you can actually
say well what's happened before and i'm
gonna do something new based on that
some pretty cool stuff um and what we're
trying to do though is communicate the
the the what the newness the exciting
things you can do with coding that no
one really understands and and that's
not just to you guys i mean it is
clearly to you guys but it's to
everybody else
right because it's i find it so
frustrating when i try and talk to
people about programming and as karen
was saying no one really understands so
here we are we actually perform in
musical venues and festivals and we're
actually starting to people go i never
realized coding could make music or i
never realized that you could actually
do interesting things with code i
thought it was really boring right and
this is the problem uh but the other
problem is like this is really
complicated
uh and this is like the kind of setup we
use and i'm happy with this i mean this
is this crazy emacs live thing which i
wrote uh with like
gsl shaders in the background it's
really hard to read the text but there's
things moving around but it looks
awesome so that's why i'm doing it um
because it's about that's the whole deal
right um and so but if we try to share
the joy of coding with more people this
is a way for them to be inspired
potentially by what you could do but
it's not what they can do now
and that's a problem if we want to get
more people doing things we need to make
the path to get to somewhere like this
if that's where they want to go
as easy as possible and so this is where
the raspberry pi foundation came in they
came along and said we really like what
you're doing sam this crazy music stuff
is there any chance you could make
something like this for the raspberry pi
i'm thinking crikey that's going to be
tough so i ported overtone and it took
seven minutes to boot
so it's like that's not going to fly so
i had to rewrite i had to rethink and
rewrite something so and it had to also
be something that was useful in the
classroom
so
how do we
provide an environment that can can do
something like this
in this kind of environment and that's
tough right it's not just about is it
easy to use it's also can i get buy-in
from teachers no do teachers think this
is actually valuable to teach
well no and
but i get there i'm sort of i've got a
trojan horse i'll show you in a second
it's really awesome uh which will get
them to understand it um and so also
they have this there's all these
political issues about programming
languages and what's an appropriate one
and what's good for apps and websites
and all sort of nonsense so we've got to
deal with all this kind of issues um
yeah so this raspberry pi is a very
small cheap computer it's like 35
it's a complete linux box you just plug
in your television and some usb keyboard
and mouse and you've got a full computer
um and so it's amazing but it's really
really low powered so that uh what you
can do in it is very limited uh so it
keeps you honest as a programmer and so
i built this thing called sonic pi which
i'll demonstrate now oh no i won't
demonstrate now at the moment uh and i
also created a scheme of work so in the
uk it's really awesome we have this new
computing curriculum in schools which is
going to start now
so we're going to teach the whole way
across from from small children up to
just before university computer science
and so that's causing a huge problem
with the teachers because a lot of the
teachers i.t teachers
are skilled in teaching office skills
which is kind of useful but it's clearly
not really what what we wanted to teach
them it's not programming it's not
understanding how the computer works
it's not understanding that they can
make the computer do what they want with
it it's just using it as a tool for
emails and spreadsheets and logo design
and yeah so i have a scheme of works
this is a lesson plan for teaching
computer science introductory computer
science using this sonic pi system and
uh i'll get to what sonic prize in a
moment
but
once i built that once i'd used it and
it was it was fun and people with
teachers are using it it was enjoyable
the problem was
as a system for live coding music it was
absolutely terrible it just made these
beeps and bleeps and you could like you
could make the beeps separate with time
but the timing was broken you know so
and you could use threads i taught
threads to get things like the baseline
and melody at the same time but again
when you use threads although you could
hear them concurrently they were totally
out of sync and on the raspberry pi it
was just utterly diabolical but the kids
didn't mind it right they were enjoying
these beeps and sleeps um but i was
thinking like how do i it's the thing
which is fun for teachers to use and
kids to play with but it's not something
that i'd want to use in a performance i
wouldn't go and use this thing
so i started embarking on thinking about
how we can expand salute pies so one of
the things we did is we got some money
from the arts council so the uk has this
thing called the arts council which uh
it has a massive pot of money and gives
it out for artistic pursuits so you
apply for it so we applied for it and we
we got these artists some actual artists
to engage to learn how to program so
they they hadn't programmed they're all
like really top professional artists in
the uk doing really amazing
installations so we convinced them to
come learn how to program and then they
were taking sonic pi and i was coding
essentially i fought it five ways and
then explored five different
approaches for them to do their art
pieces a couple of examples rob smith he
um he did a very nice project where he
used the camera in the raspberry pi to
take a photo converted the photo into
pixels and the pixels into audio and
then played the audio out over the
speakers and then uh wrote a little
program to then turn it back into a
picture so you can see here on the right
you've got a very pixelated grayscale
image of trees now for us that's not
super exciting maybe but for everybody
else in the world it's really amazing
it's like magic how do you turn a
picture into sounds and then the sounds
back into a picture my frost is about
information and abstraction and data
structures and representations and it's
all clearly obvious to us but these are
the things we miss when we try and
communicate to other people the
importance of of this and the value and
the benefits of being able to see
information as as as a conduit and new
ways to communicate new kinds of
information um another beautiful thing
is kate she
she she was really struggling for a long
time and she was she
the most artistic thing she was doing
with this raspberry pie because she was
so frustrated with it was she realized
it got really hot and so she's still
what can i do with this i can melt
chocolate
and she put it on a bar of chocolate and
she melted the the chocolate and that
was like this is this so it was like a
sign of frustration but in the last
minute she came round and she did this
which was a live you can't receive this
picture but it's a live coded
performance so she was writing event
handlers uh which were responding to her
key presses which then played sounds of
key presses so she was banging on this
keyboard really hard and the sound was
coming back with more keyboard presses
based on the events and as she was
coding she was changing the sounds into
new sounds and this performance evolved
into this really beautiful thing and
she'd never coded before and here she
was doing a live coded performance in
front of a whole bunch of people as her
artistic outcome and that's i thought
that was a really beautiful thing
um and then we applied for a whole ton
of money like 130 000 pounds and uh we
got it and the deal was to take sonic
pie this beeps and sleeps which i
haven't shown you yet because it was
very embarrassing um
uh which is also installed on all the
raspberry pi which is pretty cool uh and
we thought well how do we take this and
to make something that i'm happy with
performing with that's actually going to
be interesting from a musical
perspective and can we not just use it
to teach computer science in schools can
we use computing to teach music
can programming languages be a bona fide
a musical instrument
in schools
and so i created a single sonic pi which
i'll very quickly show you um i also
have a mac version let's see if i can
get out of this thing here we are uh
this is sonic pi so it looks absolutely
identical on the raspberry pi
this is a very basic app you can see
i've got like a documentation system
with a tutorial
welcome friends welcome friends um and
yeah you can you can like do all sorts
of cool stuff like stretching samples
and parameterization and we've got
envelopes so like you can attack things
with decays and
phasing in and like full adsl envelope
stuff and this explains what's going on
um
and uh the simplest program you can
write that's pretty cool let's get rid
of that uh it's like this
if i can make a sound
can we hear that
no
can you hear that i can't hear it at all
so i trust i can hear it can we turn the
sound up at all is that possible
right okay right so you can press play
15. that's the first program that's like
the hello world of sonic pine and and
you don't have to do any like project
creation or all that kind of nonsense or
create a new class or instantiate
something and constructors and no you
just write the word play in a 50 and you
can make it bigger if you want and then
you're done if you want to make a melody
right you like sleep for sort of
0.5 seconds and play octave higher
wicked we're in
and then this is what they do right so
this is actually this is enough to do
most of western notation these two
commands like time is when to play the
notes and pictures how high right and so
with these two things you can go
absolutely nuts you can and so they do
actually kids will just write play sleep
play sleep for hours um but then you
couldn't say well once you've got
playstation for hours maybe you might
want to use some structures i can do
some loops so i sort of loop this
guy then you can start to understand the
loops going around it's like a circle
and you can actually hear that 62 is
played at the same time as 50 because
it's loop brand so if you want to make
them separated put another sleep in
there we are off they go
and then the certain realize that they
can actually change the synths i won't
do that now i'll do it in a second and
they can also play samples like this is
a cool one
this is very quiet i'm sorry i don't
know how to make it louder
um oh thank you very much louder that's
good we want louder
right so they can play that and then
they can also change the rate so this is
we can explore different genres of music
right so that's like drum and bass there
we are um what about hip-hop old-school
early hip-hop
let's straight out of constant style and
then
we're under like gaba or something we
just do 1.5
now we're off and so they've got what
the hell the three numbers and so you
can talk about importance of that and
then because the other thing is if you
try and get kids engaged playing games
and you say to them right we're going to
make a game and python pie game whatever
and you say to them and they go wow
that's amazing we can do that we can
make a game so yes we can make a game
i'm a programmer i can show you how to
do this and then you say to them so what
kind of game do you want and they say
right
i'm on a horse
and i'm on a hill i'm looking down at a
castle and i've got my army behind me
and we're going to storm it
yeah and i'm going to plan the
strategies of the attack uh and i'm
going to make sure and you think well i
can do you a circle
that's your horse
and you think
and like when i was a kid that was
amazing like whoa but today with the
xbox it's not gonna happen so what's the
equivalent of so if we're gonna do this
guy like loop uh sample our men
do
sleep for the sample uh
duration of loop rmn let's make it back
a normal rate
uh oh i'll show you something a second
end
all right we've got a loop right that's
really quite fun
what have you do minus one
backwards i go nuts for that
right um but then the cool thing is you
can put some like randomization here so
right let's go either minus one or one
or naught point five
and let's choose one of those guys
all right we're already getting
something that sounds a bit interesting
but we all know there's like there's two
things missing um the first one is that
all music needs reverb like that's the
first lesson
so to get reverb we just need to say
with underscore effects reverb do so we
wrap whatever code we want with with
this stuff i need to write correctly
so now we've got reverb
and of course we need some bass so let's
get this some sample
bass
so seven lines of code seven lines of
code right
so i haven't seen it yet so how long
have i got karen to talk maybe two more
minutes all right so in the health
system there's some examples so uh like
you can do blue monday by new order
here we go so like blue monday is like
the drums one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven eight
one two right and then a snare and then
some some notes
so the cool thing about this is playing
on its own right now you're going to be
happy with that i can start modifying
this stuff
change the cutoff to b70 next time
rounds
that's quite nice but about like 120 so
next time it's gonna
crazy cut off
now we're going to modulate between the
two notes twice as fast
put some randomization in here
all right i need to actually put this
either way because it wouldn't use that
value as a constant platform
it's moving around now
all right enough of that another one
which is quite fun is this uh driving
pulse this is like the closest i've got
to sort of death punk like stones
again i can sort of change
now the cool thing about this right is
that what i'm showing you here
uh it's quite fun i've taught all the
constructs in here to 12 year old
children in six weeks so there's nothing
here that 12 year olds can't do after
six lessons of work
we get some echo
wow that's nice i can do that um
i gotta keep going for ages and that's
the nice thing i'm on a train right
going to london and i just do that the
whole journey and you do
you know like sounds of the ocean no
seriously right no honestly this is a
beautiful thing that's available to you
now like you can if you want to on the
train just chill out and make some music
it's a beautiful thing really it's
beautiful um
sorry for stopping you from laughing
ocean sounds
and then i'll just finish on this
get some trombike sounds going on
you can download this now
i'll give you url if you email me um
i'll make a i i was gonna make a website
which i've made but i haven't actually
put online yet so
you'll be able to easily download it
very soon if you want to play with this
now
just just to finish off um
we gave a workshop how long have i got
karen two minutes one minute no time go
besides right workshop
me
in the junction which is like a
cambridge environment we got 60 kids
programming we told them how to program
in a week they did live coding battles
so this is actually jamming on stage
battling and battling and battling and
battling and groups of them came to
battle and they had a lot of fun it was
joyful right and these people never
realized that coding was a beautiful
thing and they could make music with it
the whole bands were formed right so
you've got these guys here piping their
guitars into the laptop with this girl
here just modifying and changing in real
time
right they hadn't done this before a
week before
more cool this was amazing this ladder
was just fantastic and uh we've got the
live coding with the psych pioneers get
ready to hear some proper music boom
looping washes and all that sort of
stuff it's also decided
on all the raspberry pies next to the
wolfram language in mathematica which is
pretty cool sonic pie
and the final point before i stop now is
that um we're not at all anywhere near
complete in this journey because when i
gave the first lessons to the schools
one of the girls well the whole class
gave me this beautiful car lots of thank
yous and one of them was thank you for
making dull lifeless computers
interesting and almost reality
i don't know why i don't know why you're
clapping right i don't actually i don't
know why you're clapping because this is
depressing
like why is it people think this is the
starting point right clearly for us it's
not dull and lifeless but for other
people even after our lessons of music
in schools which is like crazy cool they
still think it's dull and lifeless so
it's really this is our mission your
mission my mission is to change people's
perspective of what computing is to not
make it dull and lifeless and to make it
badass um and so one of the approaches
we're trying to do is we're going to try
and demonstrate how badass programming
is with this new thing we're going to do
is that right that's right are you ready
i think so oh crikey right okay well i'm
going to have to strip off
change gears
oh yeah
so i program a t-shirt all right okay
are we gonna get jonathan on stage uh
this is jonathan who's the half of
medical my mic on too okay great
miss jonathan
wait wait we have to unveil the
i'm gonna surprise and get this the
surprise
the the thing
are we ready ready for it
okay so this
this
is craig
craig andera
where is he here there there
wait wait wait for it
it's going to be awesome
no expensive space look at that
look at that he made that
it's awesome
okay so uh
medex they're an awesome awesome
live coding band and the way if you
haven't heard them they're playing at
the city
museum the other night so they do
code
closure code
and uh they generate music from the code
so
the way it works is they're both jacked
into the same rebel process creating the
sounds
and what they're going to do is ship me
off messages were networked they're
going to ship me off messages of beat
and amplitude
and then i have
semi-choreographed moods but i'm still
live live rebel giving them the
combinations
of the robots
so so many points of failure right
so we have the sphero
this is one of the robots
communicates via bluetooth and if we're
connected to it
we can get it to change color
which is totally cool i have my helper
devin here is going to catch robots if
they roll off the stage
thank you so much this is a community
effort this really is
um
so we also have a roomba
right okay
um
let's see i was connected before but
once i move him he's also connected by
bluetooth it's actually a rude tooth are
you getting any messages karen uh let me
send i'm getting messages
i am getting messages what are you
getting what are you getting beat four
what do i know b15
what about
25
b25 yeah trust us good yeah it's working
we're good okay
so let me see if i uh can control the
room but two
the roomba
if he's controlled
will uh play a note
you couldn't hear he can like make music
too but way not as good as them
so
and then we also have this hexapod that
is like ultra cool
um so if he is he can go like
so yeah
he's way cool
um and we also have um a drone and
usually i fly it
like without a leash but
in the in the space it's going to be a
leash and it's anchored to a water
bottle most of the time it holds it if
it
but we'll see
so
try some spread some magic powder on it
yeah we'll keep him over here and we'll
bring him over closer to the x
when we get going
okay
right
oh wait wait wait i gotta get my actions
going again hold on
i gotta listen to your messages so you
guys are all set up
only one more thing i gotta so there's
an osc handler that i'm listening to
and i am
going to tell them to listen to the
messages
um do you just want to do like an
amplitude to send it to the skier to
make sure he's
he's going
2.5
it's hard to sell it's kind of dark
dizzy is he going
do we have the disco ball going
we need to plug it in oh we're going to
[ __ ] you totally need to plug it in
it's not a real parties until the best
disco ball is going yeah yeah and some
of you like have finger things like
finger lights because i had like these
extra finger lights totally feel free to
use it three two
one okay
cool
there we go
oh look at that yes
it's going crazy fast
all right well let's
let's try to do something right are you
okay ryan we're in jonathan
make some sounds yeah
there should be some sounds
um
uh-oh do we have audio
i hear some sounds it's coming it's
coming
okay
where's he going
i don't know i'm going to try to make
him roll he's flashing actually
all right i think he's going now watch
out for my drone let's step on them
go there
okay so he's rolling and flashing with
the beat there
oh it's amazing
flashing in the amplitude and he's going
kind of crazy
i'm gonna stop him
we didn't rehearse this part
all right i stopped them
should i go again
okay i'm changing the color
oh i think we're ready yeah we're ready
okay let's go all right we are next to
what's what's it what else do you got
this crazy ball what's this thing it
looks like a vacuum cleaner
oh oh i started him again okay
all right so the roomba is going to now
respond to your beat
oh that's way too fast
there we go
there we go
you can make him go forward and backward
you ready devin
i'm gonna make him go forward and
backward you
at
ready
all right let's get them both together
hey
i try to get more
let's do the hexapod
he's got some crazy moves
again i'm going let's see
all right i could try to make them walk
maybe let's move them over a little bit
we'll do hexapod crawling music again i
think they go hexagon crawling music
okay ready let's go
we'll go back to the other one
all right should we get them all three
going together
yes absolutely can you actually do that
though i don't believe you can do that i
don't either that's that's concurrency
isn't it
concurrency
using clojure
can't do that
all right don't believe it let's try
them getting them all together at the
same time
foreign
all right
what's that
this is the parrot ar drone it's a
quadcopter
and um
is it dangerous
sometimes
all right i have a tough show
uh it won't cut your fingers but it will
hurt okay believe me yes
okay so let's just try to get him into
the air
and we're going to try to get them
hovering on the room but if we can
yeah
totally good
okay let's see if we can get him to
dance too
i can't tell what he's doing because i'm
turned around
over there
you think we should try getting them all
together at the same time
whoa
all right
we'll get them in the air one more time
and then we'll get them all going we're
gonna go like the grand finale is it
gonna be free for all that points yeah
yeah we offer our leads we're just gonna
let it all go we don't have to do the
same things the same sounds other sounds
you can do other stands really yeah
reading yeah
it's great
oh
it does hurt
all right
i think that's as good as it's gonna get
all right let's go
that's down
oh
all right i'll turn it back and forth
more let's do some more we've got like
we've got some more audio
yeah see
look at the people look at the people
again
so
foreign
chat
foreign
foreign
what's up
cool
look at me